tôt ou tard, les humains vont
nous combattre ici vous auriez dû savoir que
ce jour arrivait
sommes-nous censés suivre notre roi et
rester dans une maladie silencieuse nous devons aller
à Paris maintenant nous nous sommes cachés ici trop
longtemps allons à  une maison légitime si nous
étions sur terre nous aurions une
planète glorieuse sur laquelle
prospérer tu parles de trahir
ton frère tu parles de
liberté tu es aveugle à ses intentions
bonnes ou mauvaises il est dangereux de quoi je
parle  est la liberté la liberté à travers
tous chez les humains allez-vous utiliser votre
voix et tuer votre seul frère